allez on prend la direction de chanceaux
près loches pour notre page était
consacrée ce week-end à cet écrivain
disparu au début du mois d'août
gonzague saint-bris ce laisse derrière
lui beaucoup d'amis beaucoup d'ouvragés
sur tout ce festival littéraire la forêt
des livres où l'émotion est forte
aujourd'hui sur place on retrouve fabien
flavien techs et oui bonsoir olivia que
d'émotion aujourd'hui
en fait on achève notre grand week-end
dans le lochois avec cette journée et
bien si particulière aujourd'hui à la
forêt des livres des milliers de
visiteurs des milliers d'anonymes sont
venus ici en quelque sorte rendre un
dernier hommage à gonzague saint bris et
puis je le disais à la mi journée c'est
le monde de la culture qui est présent
ici avec comme chaque année des
écrivains bien sûr mais également des
cinéastes des réalisateurs des comédiens
des chanteurs tous sont présents à cette
22e édition
on va parler tout de suite de gonzague
saint-bris ce avec quelqu'un que vous
connaissez bien puisqu'il s'agit de
franz olivier giesbert gonzague saint
bris
c'est un ami
je ne dirais pas ça tout à fait je
connaissais depuis très très longtemps
et c'est quelqu'un que j'adorais par
hasard absolument extraordinaire
quelques semaines avant ça mange écrit
un article dans le point
mais comment dire j'ai commencé en
disant d'antan tout bonnement gueuler
parce que je veux dire du bien de
gonzague gêner son dernier livre je
tourne fort mais là je trouve c'est
l'enfant de d'andré castello et d'alain
decaux qui nous ont fait aimer
l'histoire et ce livre épique merveille
c'était l'histoire déshabiller et
gonzague je l'aimé je pas dit c'est la
vie on est chacun d'un côté j'avais
envie de lui dire comme ça quelques
temps avant sa mort subite l'accidentel
et je suis très heureux de l'avoir fait
et du coup ils étaient tellement émue
par ce papier qui m'a appelé du tout le
peuple et vient ça fait des années que
je disais l'année prochaine parce que
j'avais toujours des activités d'autres
choses à faire et je lui dis ouais je
viens je viens installé et puis voilà
est arrivé ce qui est arrivé
je suis très heureux d'être là pour
témoigner parce que c'est quelqu'un qui
était bienveillant
peut-être que beaucoup de gens le
prenaient pas au sérieux c'est quelqu'un
de généreux qui savait admirer raconteur
d'histoires absolument exceptionnel j'ai
eu la chance et d'aller mais des
conférences c'est lui qui faisait le
baratin mais c'était dingue
surtout quand ont animé parce que vous
interrompez sans arrêt avec des
anecdotes des histoires et que ses
imitations des dialogues etc
non enfin voilà go sachs était une belle
personne
je suis content d'être venu aujourd'hui
pour le dire voilà le clamer et le dire
on poursuit notre page était avec des
images du café littéraire c'est le
rendez vous incontournable ici chaque
année
regardez
le café littéraire comme chaque année en
plein air à la tribune les personnalités
se succèdent pour évoquer la mémoire de
gonzague
une manifestation qui prend un tour
particulier robert hossein richard
bohringer tous sont venus raconter
l'écrivain à leur manière dans le public
la foule des anonymes écoute c'est
important pour vous d'être là
aujourd'hui depuis la disparition de
gonzague
oui tout à fait pourquoi c'est une façon
de rendre hommage d'être là aussi pour
lui
des anonymes habitué de la forêt des
livres
certains sont venus quand on voit ça et
envir tourangelle sa disparition
ça m'a touché tous les ans à la forêt
des livres c'est vrai que il avait
vraiment le charisme pour présenter pour
le moment pour lui ça pour en jouer
disque important c'est de représenter la
région par quelqu'un qui connaît la
région
enfin que vous êtes venu aujourd'hui
pour ça et puis aussi pour rencontrer
des personnes vivant des artistes qu'on
pourrait apprendre à connaître mieux
mais il ya tellement parlé
personnellement avec le savent mais peu
importe coucou aujourd'hui l'essentiel
c'était bien d'être là est notre
deuxième invité ce soir c'est marine
jobert saint-brice connaissiez depuis
longtemps non depuis quatre mois j'ai
rencontré pour la première fois il ya
quatre mois je fais il a fait fait un
dîner chez lui j'ai découvert un
personnage délicieux et nous avons
tellement bien accrocher tous les deux
que
j'ai eu une idée lui dire écoute et vous
avez vous connaissez tellement de choses
sur l'histoire
comment faire pour donner envie aux
enfants d'en savoir un peu plus sur
notre pays sur l'histoire avec un grand
h de notre pays voulait pas mais dès que
l'on fasse des chroniques ensemble et
que je les raconte
il y avait trouvé cette idée formidable
donc nous avions ce projet là tous les
deux et puis voilà quoi
il est là gonzague aujourd'hui il est là
et je lui avais fait cette promesse et
et il faut que cette forêt des livres
continuent d'exister parce que c'est
tellement formidable
je suis époustouflée devant le nombre de
chevaux qui viennent je croyais que les
gens lisent et polluent c'est pas vrai
ils aiment lire ils aiment découvrir
je suis très étonné très surprise et
très heureuse merci à vous marine jobert
et voilà ainsi s'achève notre page était
dans le lochois vendredi nous étions à
beaulieu-lès-loches pour la restauration
de l'église abbatiale hier à loches sur
les traces de gonzague saint-bris ces
puits aujourd'hui ici à la forêt des
livres
c'était bien pour viendra